dans un instant nous parlerons de haute
couture mais auparavant un phénomène au
japon la mode des vêtements de rue des
frites pour la plupart d'occasions
notamment les chaussures usagées qui se
vendent plus cher que les neuf autres
enquêtes de ce soir menée par stéphane
haumant et christian hottin est intitulé
des uniformes de la révolte
tokyo la stresser tokyo la tentaculaire
compte millions d'habitants banlieue
comprise dans cet univers de béton
standard la jeunesse réinvente samon
postez vous à n'importe quel coin de rue
le défilé permanent un peu de provoc
beaucoup d'humour mais jamais
l'agressivité
tout marche le style collège clown
néo-hippie lycéenne à socquettes pisser
ou traditionnels japonais détourner la
tendance est au mélange au collage
personnel
il y en a pour tous les goûts et surtout
pour toutes les couleurs
une seule règle être différent à tout
prix
certains jours je dépense jusqu'à 3000
francs aux vêtements il ne reste rien
pour moi la rue avant j'avais les
cheveux bleu marine est mauvaise les
différences mais ça ne me plaît pas je
vais bientôt changer
développer les marques c'est trop cher
sinon on achète ou d'occasion fait les
échanges avec nos âmes et au marché aux
puces les grandes marques ne sont plus
en vogue
l'argent facile et les années 80 sont
bien loin aujourd'hui tokyo aussi s'est
mise à la récup paradoxe la fripe devenu
à la mode est souvent plus cher que le
neuf
souvenez vous vos vieilles baskets
usagers elles sont peut-être ici et
elles se vendent une fortune
cette paire d'adidas d'occasion vo 1300
francs j'ai d'autres modèles qui peuvent
monter jusqu'à 13 musc en 2047 11 20 un
nom énigmatique pour l'une des boutiques
les plus branchés tokyo les jeunes
stylistes rivalisent d'imagination pour
séduire la jeunesse
ici les créateurs ont moins de 30 ans et
ils ont déjà ouvert trois magasins
leur philosophie est assez éloigné de la
traditionnelle discrétion japonaise
notre message est très simple il faut
savoir s'amuser dans la vie il faut
profiter des bonnes choses et s'éclater
pour la frime en français dans le texte
tout est permis
mais la révolte n'a qu'un temps à 25 ans
en moyenne les jeunes japonais entrent
dans la vie active et il endosse tout
naturellement l'uniforme de la vie de
bureau
la vraie